the crisis at America's Southern border
right now an average of 2500 people are
Crossing into El Paso Texas every single
day men women and children and that
number could soon Skyrocket with the
expiration of a pandemic era rule that
made it easier to turn back migrants a
ruling on that could come later today
Lydia Luciano spoke to some of those
seeking asylum in this country about why
they are here what changes in U.S policy
could mean to them Lea is at a makeshift
shelter in El Paso Lilia good morning to
you A lot of people waiting for this
decision
that's right Gail good morning well
yesterday I heard from people waiting to
make their claim for Asylum to cross the
border families from Colombia Venezuela
Nicaragua Ecuador fleeing persecution
violence threats they know that next
week could be a very important date if
title 42 is lifted on Wednesday they
know the lines to try to get across will
be longer but maybe their chances to
stay could be brighter
along the dusty crowded Edge where El
Paso meets Mexico hundreds of refugees
and migrants await an uncertain future
despite the doubts little faces beemed
hopeful
because you're so close to arriving
gladys's Joy almost masked her parents
exhaustion after a 20-day Journey from
Ecuador where they say criminal gangs
extorted them and threatened to harm
their young daughter
so what do you hope will happen
[Music]
um
a good life a good future to study and
to have a good job one day here at the
final stretch the roles reversed it was
young Gladys comforting her mother
who lamented how fast her child was
forced to grow
several times a day border patrol opens
up the gates to let dozens of migrants
in to be processed and many are released
to wait for an asylum Hearing in the U.S
the agency says if title 42 expires is
planned next week the expected numbers
to increase dramatically
over in ciudad Juarez Mexico staring at
the line from a distance other migrants
wait what are you waiting for
eign
when these men left Venezuela the U.S
was taking in migrants from their
country but along the journey the U.S
policy changed Mexico agreed to take in
Venezuelan migrants and now they're
forced to stay there feeling unsafe
they hope their luck is about to change
what do you think will happen if title
42 does expire next week
[Music]
DHS has announced a six-point plan for
the lifting of title 42 that includes
increasing efficiency to process people
and also sending more resources to
border cities like this one where we are
this is a cardboard Warehouse that the
owner opened up as a makeshift shelter
because the streets are full of people
who are having to sleep in the cold
flat
Lilia thank you very much